we all remember Derek Jeter's iconic
final home game at Yankee Stadium but
you probably didn't notice this ball boy
make an incredible finesse worth
thousands in 2014 Derek Jeter came up
for his last at-bat and hit a foul ball
down the left field at the bottom of the
fifth typically a ball boy will give a
foul ball to a fan in the stands
thinking quickly on his feet this ball
boy swapped the ball and gave the Fate
to a fan and kept the real ball for
himself which nearly quadrupled its
value but why this is because the foul
ball never left the field making its
value shoot up from 2000 to 10 thousand
dollars it was a smooth finesse indeed
who can blame him